the Joe Rogan experience no comes don't
have any of that no least you guys don't
have bears that's when it really is a
pain in the ass and people got coyotes
now though I bet you do yeah so a couple
of those walking through the yard yeah
and they're you know I have no pets so
yeah we've lost pets I used to have
someone I used to have so many pets I
had everything yeah dogs cats goats
horses without them I do yeah I do
it's just you don't really realize it
until you know you you're closing the
sliding door you're opening it up and
you're not thinking [ __ ] Yeah right if
someone gonna get out you know very free
that's a weird thing to always feel bad
the cats can't even go outside well they
can't go outside in Texas they'll get
eaten yeah but it's just sad that they
can't even go outside like what the [ __ ]
kind of life is that just living in a
little prison like a you know in a cage
yeah no I don't like goldfish I'm like
any of that goat so had a lot of goats
those are mean [ __ ] yeah that's
horses - I am I had a thing my daughter
had horses and like I had a castle in
the in Belgium we had and two horses
there you got a castle in Belgium yeah I
just have money no no I took my company
public in 96 called
think new ideas and it was one of the
first internet marketing advertising
companies and it was big we had 400
people it was a big company Wow
and yeah my buddy and I we just worked
out and we took it public and back then
it was like this is before the real
dot-com craze so we raised twenty
million dollars like holy [ __ ] we
couldn't believe it which is nothing
these days and after all the lawyers and
every wanted taken their money there was
15 million left and so we started to
build the business and what we're
talking about hassle you know castle
yeah so there was that and then I'd also
at the time someone had said I did
pretty well on the on the IPO and I'm
not crazy but you know okay there's a
you know I learned what dilution means I
learned that pretty quick but I'd
invested $50,000 in some company and
then I in 2000 just for two
thousand moved to Amsterdam move back to
the Netherlands and the bank called me
said you sitting down yeah what's up
said remember that company you invested
in yeah well it went public it was asked
Jeeves and you now have 65 million
dollars I'm like on paper
I'm paper Joe so lock up you couldn't
sell any of it you know all this stuff
so I did get some out but you know
basically wrote it down the wallpaper
you can't sell it never well if you're
an insider right you you lock up your
shares it's a it's an SEC regulation so
you can't sell for them I think that
it's negotiable but it's it's it's so
the other investors who come in won't be
left holding the bag so you know do the
IPO and then all the insiders sell their
shares and everyone who just bought at
the IPO then all their [ __ ] goes down in
value I'm screwed so you have to there's
a lock-up typically six months or 12
months or 18 months and through some
back-ended way out the hell was going on
our bankers do it with swap and stuff
and promises and derivatives they were
able to get some money out for me that I
spent on helicopters and all kinds of
fun stuff I've enjoyed the money yeah
definitely glad I got the podcasting
thing left so how'd you get back to
Austin well I so I had the company in
San Francisco this was a different
company the podcast company and I was
going I was living in London at the time
so I lived there for five years
damn you're an international traveler I
have lived in a couple places and was
going back and forth
San Francisco London and there was a
breakup between me and my wife and we
got divorced and so I stayed in San
Francisco and then moved to California
to add to Los Angeles for about a year I
always want to live in LA lives in the
hills over like Highland and it just
didn't work for me you know I was doing
basically the podcast and that shows me
I'm like 1213 years ago and I don't know
it's just maybe it was that area but I
really had nowhere else to go and if I
wanted to go somewhere I'm just sitting
in traffic all day it's like if I want
to go the bee
no I was with a woman at the time who
was an actress I never I never marry an
actress man bad I was warned so she
wanted to be in that general area so it
just wasn't working for me and then I
did a tour from Virginia down to Florida
the Gulf Coast for the show with an RV
doing the show from the RV meeting
people doing meetups and it was it was
just around the time when the you had
the the BP oil spill in in the Gulf and
so people really depressed and it was
all messy and just was not a good vibe
and I was gonna go straight up to
Chicago and a buddy of mine
Greg Lally who was one of the true last
independent record promoters who I'd
known from San Francisco and he knew
from Chicago back from the radio days
and he said Oh Adam come to Austin
you'll love it comes to come to us who
stay at my place come to Austin like now
I mean I'd never really been to Texas
you know just like it doesn't really
interest me I'm just gonna go up to
Chicago and just kept pushing and
pushing us from driving up and then he
says or I thought to myself
Greg is flamboyantly gay single dad
adopted a kid from Ukraine and if he's
in Texas and he's still alive it can't
be that bad something maybe it's just
Austin I don't know so I visit him and
we did a meet up and this is in the
summer so it's about 112 degrees but you
know that Austin heat is not too humid
it's it's doable and there were 30 33
people at the meetup and they were all
happy and proud of their city and proud
of their state and they loved what with
just there was so much good energy
particularly after they just came from
the Gulf and one young woman her purse
fell on the ground and out rolled a
fresh pair of Underpants
and a handgun unlike Texas this is where
I've moved there three months later
[Applause]